this tick tocker plastic surgeon woman
get arrested for live streaming during
one of her surgeries her name is Dr Roxy
of course it is I knew a dancer like
that
too all yo I don't here are a couple
professions that I don't want you live
streaming surgery is one of them
pilot don't don't need that I also want
to know where you came up with this idea
were you in the middle of a surgery and
you're like you know what this life or
death stuff it's too serious
you know what may lighten this
up well The Story Goes that in one of
her surgeries she injured her patient
resulting in her license being revoked
right okay so technically just so you
know she did ask for permission to film
but still that person who she asked
permission was probably eight per
cassettes in they were like yeah I don't
give a so before per that doesn't make
your case any stronger you're performing
a surgery